说话人 1: 我是Jackson，今天给大家带来一期非常有价值的聊天
说话人 1: 为什么
说话人 1: 你们可以看到在线上可以做到整个流程的一个东西，可以让你们学习到非常多阶段的一个知识
说话人 1: OK，我们来说一下这个女生的一个背景情况
说话人 1: 这个女生她是我的学员，在群里面，代聊的一个目标，她当时是搭讪认识的
说话人 1: 值得一提的是，她在前期跟这个女生的接触当中，在聊天里面，大概聊了可能 20 多页，可能几百回合
说话人 1: 女生还是没有出来，相当于是一个黄灯，对吧
说话人 1: 她在犹豫，她的联系感不足
说话人 1: 这个时候我接手了，在群里面，大家也可以看到我是现场直播帮他聊的，没有丝毫造假的一个成分
说话人 1: 很多导师他的聊天记录，他给学员聊的都可能是造假造出来的
说话人 1: 为什么
说话人 1: 因为首先他聊的不对劲，其次他只是一张截图，对吧
说话人 1: 我的聊天是在群里面经过很多兄弟校检，经过很多兄弟验证的，所以说是 100% 真实的
说话人 1: 在我接手这个兄弟的聊天之后，差不多在 20 多个回合就把女生给聊出来了，你们可以看到在这个过程中用到了非常多的技术
说话人 1: OK，我们废话不多说，直接开始讲解
说话人 1: 你们可以看到这个学员在5月 9 号的时候发了一个聊天，给女生发了两段话，女生没有回了
说话人 1: 在5月 19 号的时候，在我的群里面，我让他开了一个场，因为当时深圳在下雨，我让他随便开了一个场，今天好大的雨
说话人 1: 女生说，你是在龙华那边下雨吗
说话人 1: 我上午在龙华，下午回龙岗这边了
说话人 1: OK，女生也描述了她的一个状态，对吧
说话人 1: 这个不重要，我们看接下来我怎么回的
说话人 1: 这里我直接无视掉她的状态，我们直接切入主题
说话人 1: 为什么在这里要切入主题
说话人 1: 还是我们的一个原则，你要去上你的男女前提，让女生知道你不是当她的闺蜜，你是要去操她的
说话人 1: 这时候我说，哎呀，别管那些了，只是想说快放晴了，想出去走走，对吧
说话人 1: 这是在埋一个铺垫邀约
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说，她说这不是刚下雨吗
说话人 1: 刚开始，很多兄弟觉得，OK，女生在拒绝他，在什么
说话人 1: No，其实不是，女生的脑子里是知道你在约她的，然后她在矜持，为了让自己看起来不是一个，对吧
说话人 1: 因为在下雨，全都怪天气，对吧
说话人 1: 然后她又不想拒绝你，因为怕失去你，因为怕失去，可能在这个时候是一个备胎，可能失去一个追求者，她是不愿意失去的，所以说在这个时候她会找一些借口
说话人 1: 然后我说你那边停了没
说话人 1: 就是我们直接把这个物流给确定好，停了我们就搞出来
说话人 1: 然后我说停了的话，它结束就代表我们可能要开始了，非常暧昧，非常强烈的一个男女意图，但是又那么的有艺术性，没有那么的一些直白
说话人 1: 就会让女生觉得，OK，这个男的有点会撩
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说咋了
说话人 1: 你开始操作了
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个很重要，这是一个关键的节点
说话人 1: 女生说咋了
说话人 1: 你要开始操作了，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是你确实撩到她了，但是有一个废物测试就来了，她会觉得你对每个女生，对很多女生都这样，因为太会了
说话人 1: OK，那么这个时候我们不要顺着她这条线，让自己看起来非常的浪，不行，我们要拉回来，把舒适感拉回来一点，这个时候就是我的操作开始了
说话人 1: 我说是我的操作，但是我的灵魂，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是OK，我是在用技巧，但是我是对你这个人有感兴，对你这个人感兴趣，我才去用技巧，而不是说只是为了技巧而技巧
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说
说话人 1: 那你操作一下，再让我见识见识
说话人 1: OK，上一个废策是过了，但是紧接着下一个废策又来了
说话人 1: 这个废策是属于他的高位废策，就是他把自己当成一个奖品，你来表现，你来演戏，或者说你来做一些什么东西来取悦我这种感觉
说话人 1: OK，我们不要进这样的框架，这个时候我敏锐的识别到了，然后我说艺术是不能出现多次的，你目前是
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 它是有两个意思，第一句话就是艺术是不能出现多次的，就是我的表演也好，我的技术也好，我的一些很的操作也好，他不能去疯狂的乱操作，操作多了就会觉得很廉价，这是第一点
说话人 1: 第二点就是你目前是什么意思
说话人 1: 就是我说它是一个艺术品，对艺术品我是需要好好的去做质量，而不是去做数量，是告诉他这样的一个逻辑
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这句话杀伤力非常的大，直接给妹子干趴了
说话人 1: 女生说好的，花的还算高级
说话人 1: 她是认可了我的话，但是还是在做她的奖品框架
说话人 1: 为什么
说话人 1: 因为学员在前面聊了 20 多页，聊了 20 多张聊天，都还没聊好，这会给女生塑造好一种奖品框架，所以到这里她还是没有完全的把她的高位给放下来
说话人 1: 这个时候我又要拉回来一点我的能量，就是我说还好有点肉麻，对吧
说话人 1: 把我的能量拉回来了，我说啊这个东西有点肉麻，我不想再说了
说话人 1: 我还给他打压了一下，我说你喜欢肉麻，知道吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个也非常的重要，这是冷读，妹子喜欢这样的话，我是能看得出来，而且她也比较有窗口，都被我看出来了，所以说我说出这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 让她自己明确的知道她是对我们有窗口的，知道吗
说话人 1: 我们能看出来女生对我们有窗口，这是我们的点，我们还要做到一个点，就是让女生彻底知道她是对我们有窗口，这样她才会破掉她的防御，懂吗
说话人 1: 这个很重要，兄弟们，这个是女性心理板块
说话人 1: 女生她接受了这样的一个复格，她说我喜欢麻，当然是食物的那种，她跟你玩起来了，很多兄弟认为这是拒绝，NO，她跟你玩起来了，她没有严肃的拒绝你，那就是接受，知道吗
说话人 1: 这个时候我说，那请你喝花胶奶茶，OK，这是做了一个铺垫的一个预设，铺垫邀约的一个预设，铺垫邀约在聊天上要持续的去做，这样才能让我们约她的时候没有那么突兀，你能在每一次铺垫
说话人 1: 邀约看到女生的一次真实的邀约窗口，所以说这是非常保险，非常稳妥的一个做法，不点邀约
说话人 1: 然后女生说她说我喝咖啡，这个时候你就知道她是愿意答应你出来了，但是这个时候我们还是要把需求感压一下，这时候我说喝咖啡不会睡不着吗
说话人 1: 就是来测一下她这个窗口到底是不是很真实，然后再把我们的需求感往回拉一下
说话人 1: 女生说睡不着跟咖啡无关，OK，这个时候我们就无视她这句话，我说你随意，我主要是见你这件事情，无论是喝咖啡也好，喝奶茶也好，我都无所谓，主要是你人在这里，对吧
说话人 1: 突出我们要见的一个主题，也是加强一下男女的一个框架
说话人 1: 然后女生说好好好，我懂，对吧
说话人 1: 就已经确定了百分之八九十了，那么这个时候我们立刻要乘胜追击，我说忘了跟你定时间了，哪天
说话人 1: 就是要去马上把这个东西给变现，立刻做好一个契约性，这样才能把这个窗口给它升级，给它变现，不然的话你聊的这些东西都没有意义了
说话人 1: 这个事也就是我们的阶段收尾的一个意义
说话人 1: 然后女生说她说这不是下雨了吗
说话人 1: 今天你约了谁
说话人 1: 女生的意思是她说有点下雨，可能有一点不想出来，这是第一点，我们要去解决掉这个问题
说话人 1: OK，下雨其实没影响，我们要去消除掉这个她自己认为的阻碍
说话人 1: 还有一点就是她说你今天约了谁，这还是一个废策，兄弟们，这是一个废策，我们先把这个物流先去解决了，她的地理位置，我们再去解决后面的一个废策
说话人 1: 我说你在哪
说话人 1: 她说啥
说话人 1: 我说今天可以见啊
说话人 1: 女生说你怎么没约别的妹妹
说话人 1: 就是她可能认为她是条鱼，这时候我们就要去解决这个问题了，因为她连续的问了两次，她还没把这个东西给解决掉，对吧
说话人 1: 我说你不也没约别的哥哥
说话人 1: 女生说她说你是主动的呀，我都是被动
说话人 1: 我说我主动99，你1，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是我可以很主动，但是你必须要你必须要配合我，我们才能一起去完成这个事情
说话人 1: 女生说她说怕不是跟别的小姐姐也这样，你们可以看出女生非常的没有安全感，因为可能我展示出的价值，展示出的属性有点短期，吸引力比较强，我们就要拉回来
说话人 1: 这个时候兄弟们我回了一个很经典的一个东西，我说
说话人 1: 我敢爱敢恨，不像你
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 就是不给女生去解释，对吧
说话人 1: 我有很多女生接触，我不去解释，我也不去直面她这个废测，我用一个防守反击的一个方式，我说我对感情就是这样，我敢爱敢恨，我不像你，又怂又找各种借口，又各种装逼，直接破掉她的防御
说话人 1: 很多时候废测，你不要去一贯的防御，知道吗
说话人 1: 你不要去一贯的防御，一贯的去在他的框架里面去解释，我们很多时候要做一个反击，你才能把敌人给打倒，不然的话你会一直处于被动，我们要拿到主动权，兄弟们
说话人 1: 然后这个女生瞬间倍感住了，她说年纪大了，体谅一下，对吧
说话人 1: 她在疯狂的解释了，OK，我们要的效果已经达到了
说话人 1: 兄弟们要知道在聊天里面，你要持续这样不断的去battle，然后把女生给打趴，直到她彻底的臣服，你才能获得你想要的结果，兄弟们
说话人 1: 然后这个时候我在
说话人 1: 做一个鼓励，我说不试一次怎么知道还会不会冲动
说话人 1: 我在鼓励她去做投资，这个女生她为了不让自己输，她发了一个表情流汗，她说咋说
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们可能会被这样的表情干住，知道吗
说话人 1: 我知道你们，兄弟们，你会被这样的表情给干住，为什么
说话人 1: 因为在我很久很久以前，我也被这样的表情给干住，在我准备真情流露的时候，女生发了一个很不解风情的一个表情，一个什么的话，对吧
说话人 1: 但是不要怕，这只是她不敢去投资，不敢往深的投资的一种体现，她想让男人先撕开自己的面具，她才敢脱下她自己的衣服，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我们就一定要坚持住，我说见，今天就我把我的目的完全说出来，我们要见了才能把这些东西聊清楚
说话人 1: 还有一个点
说话人 1: 我说你吃了吗
说话人 1: 这是在做什么
说话人 1: 这是在做一个假定成交
说话人 1: 如果说，真的，这个技巧非常重要，假定成交
说话人 1: 如果说我说你吃了吗
说话人 1: 他说你干嘛
说话人 1: 我不出来，什么什么，他会直接拒绝你
说话人 1: 但是只要他说他吃与没吃，那都代表我们是可以去做邀约的，懂不懂
说话人 1: 这是一个非常好用的一个技巧
说话人 1: 然后女生说，她说还没有吃，OK，我们马上抓到机会，立刻开始进行一个变现
说话人 1: 我说跟你聊挨了一会饿了，要不走
说话人 1: 跟你聊挨了一会饿了，这是在合理化，我们要很紧急的去约她，你要立刻马上我们来见面，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是做一个场景的一个铺垫
说话人 1: 我们还为了我们下一句合理化，要不走，对吧
说话人 1: 加强一下他的一个语气，是这样的一个作用
说话人 1: 女生说她说今天外面很难排，可能是到周末，对吧
说话人 1: 可能是下雨，OK，她怕有点难排队
说话人 1: 学员他是在群里跟我说，他说他有海底捞的免排特权，因为他可能是VIP，OK，他想说把他的海底捞 VIP 身份发给这个女生，他说可以展示价值嘛，我说没必要，这个不是什么身份，对吧
说话人 1: 这也不需，这也不是一个很强大的特权，你只需要给到女生一种我能搞定一切的感觉，她就没有顾虑了
说话人 1: 所以说在这里我给出了一个话术，这个话术它不是一个很神奇的作用，但是它很有艺术性，同时也代表了我能扛住所有责任的一个意思，让女生彻底的放松
说话人 1: 我说我安排，听党指挥，能打胜仗
说话人 1: 女生秒回啊，回的很快，她说去哪里
说话人 1: 我还想说要不要在家里吃点，女生还在犹豫，可以看到这个女生她是非常的优柔寡断的，非常的谨慎的，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这种女生可能看起来短期，但实际上她是比较长期的女生，她是非常谨慎的，她没有那么有安全感，这个时候我们需要识别到
说话人 1: 我让学员给她发了一个位置，女生又出现了一些问题，因为地理位置有点远，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员发了一个你在哪
说话人 1: 就是知道她的位置
说话人 1: OK，你们需要去调度，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是在调度你和女生的一个行程安排，你需要知道她的地点、你的地点、你们约的地方、你们的时间，各方面都需要你去调度，不要让女生去调度，你要让女生最大的动能、最大的激励出来
说话人 1: 同时能让你最大程度的让自己很轻松，让自己没那么费劲，知道吗
说话人 1: 这就是我们相当于是一个谈判的一个效果，但是没有那么严重
说话人 1: 学员是不想去那么远嘛，对吧
说话人 1: 这里我帮他支了一些招，看试探女生究竟是什么情况，不愿意从那么远过来
说话人 1: 于是我先说，我给你叫个车吧，排队你不担心
说话人 1: 我还给做第二个选项，还是得晕车，不想太远，知道吗
说话人 1: 我们要把所有的情况分析出来，让女生做选择，我们不要让女生去做一个责任的一个付出
说话人 1: 你要让她选 A 或者选 B 就行了
说话人 1: 在女生想选的时候让她选，在女生不想选的时候不要给她选项，这是灵活的，不是说你听到某些 PUA 课程，你说啊不要给女生选择，直接去做决定，no，那是很的，那是没有成熟的体系
说话人 1: 然后女生说啥日子啊
说话人 1: 你 12 点能见到我吗
说话人 1: 我怀疑，因为女生很怕堵
说话人 1: OK，但是让她有点夸张，对吧
说话人 1: 只是为了掩饰她不想出来，只是为了让你去要不下次吧，让你说出这样的话
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们要来一波激将法，做一个试狗，然后把这个东西立刻给它加强去变现，我说怎么跟个女人一样磨磨唧唧的，对吧
说话人 1: 实际上我就是想说她别逼逼，别墨迹，只是用上了一个技术性的表达手法，怎么跟个女人一样
说话人 1: 然后我在用这句话的时候，这是我自己发明的一个话术，我在用这句话的时候
说话人 1: 一般女人 99% 都会回，啊，就是女人啊，对吧
说话人 1: 情绪就出现了，这个时候我们刚好去做决定，更好去改变她的一些决定
说话人 1: 然后她说我是女人啊，你要跟我做兄弟吗
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 情绪已经出来了，哪怕她说这样的话，你们感觉不出情绪，但我知道情绪已经出来了，这个时候我就能去影响她的一些决定
说话人 1: 然后我无视她这样的一些回答，我直接说你化妆要多久
说话人 1: 然后女生说你先随便吃点好吗
说话人 1: 就是可能会耽误比较久，她说晚点再过来，这时间碰不上
说话人 1: 我说好，到了你饿了再吃点，就是我们还会见，我还是要给她把这样的预期做出来
说话人 1: 很多时候我们要去流转女生的决定，必须要自己坚持
说话人 1: 然后我说出门时跟我说吧，然后隔了一阵子，女生说你要不要过来
说话人 1: 我还没吃饭呢
说话人 1: 然后我说不早说，现在我来吧
说话人 1: 然后女生还在那里，因为她其实她不是不想见，她是觉得很麻烦，这里我们要加强一下自己的投资进度，让女生知道这个东西是没有可选项的
说话人 1: 我说一半了，到了说
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说她说我还在朋友家呢，她在做饭
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 她还是在做一个假性的拒绝，她说啊，我在朋友那里，我还没吃饭，什么要不要你晚点过来，这样的一个意思
说话人 1: OK，我说多久
说话人 1: 今天能见吗
说话人 1: 我不跟她逼逼，我不跟她逼逼，我直接让她做一个快速的一个，她想要的心里面的一个决定，因为她怕得罪我的话，她就必须想见，她就必须要见，这是人下意识的反应，所以说这个东西它是很好用的
说话人 1: 然后女生说能，还在做饭，你到哪里了
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: OK，这个时候就已经确定了，然后 10 分钟到你发的定位处，然后女生说饭都还在做，笑死，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候就已经完全的她接受了见面的一个场景了，然后我在这里上了一个框架，我说我不喜欢迟到，我先吃东西了，好了叫我
说话人 1: 然后这里我们才知道女生最大的一个顾虑，这个时候她才出现，她说你介意吗
说话人 1: 我素颜，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是这段话的一个主要的信息，她害怕你看到她不好看，对吧
说话人 1: 因为女生的素颜都是很丑的，特别是这个女生她还强调了我素颜，就代表她素颜可能真的比较丑
说话人 1: 就是可能没有眉毛，看起来很没精神
说话人 1: 兄弟们，不是你们想的那种丑，不是，是跟她化妆之后完全是两个人，这个很正常，不代表她是，这只是她气血不足，或者说她的眉毛比较稀少，看起来就不好看
说话人 1: 我在这里用了一个消除评判的话术，我说第一次见真实一点好
说话人 1: 女生说什么怕吓到你，对吧
说话人 1: 她还是有顾虑，这个时候我们要给出一个很好的一个阅历来破解她这个东西，这个可能一般兄弟没法去理解，但我在这里告诉你们，我说我不是没见过女人素颜哦，你越说我越好奇
说话人 1: OK，就是让她知道我其实见过很多女人素颜，我知道，OK，女人素颜是什么样子，会比较丑，我还能接受，对吧
说话人 1: 我没有什么评判，让女生知道这个信息，她就会瞬间打开
说话人 1: 女生，你看，兄弟们一下子就打开了，说哈哈哈，好好好
说话人 1: 你在哪里随便吃了点，对吧
说话人 1: 到时候就直接邀约了，到那个点他们就直接见面了，非常快速的一个邀约，在差不多一两个小时之内就搞定了
说话人 1: 你们要想一想，兄弟们，这是一个没有窗口，甚至黄灯，甚至偏红灯的一个女生，给她聊成这样，立刻邀约出来做一个变现
说话人 1: 同时兄弟们，你们可以看到我的操作非常的凶险，这个女生很多很谨慎，很奇葩的一些问题都需要去解决
说话人 1: 这个东西不是一两天都能学会的，它是要长年累月的一个社交直觉，以自己的阅历积累才能搞定这样的一个东西，才能把这个女生给干住，不然很多时候你们只能吃定率的
说话人 1: 差不多就是这样，后面学员去约了一个足浴，在足浴里面尝试一些收尾一些操作，也是我给他的一些建议，因为很多兄弟可能没在足浴，可能没跟女生约过足浴，可能没去做过这样的一个情景，但是在我的经验里面，足浴是非常放松的，也是比较中性的一个环境，他可以去往男女方面延伸，他也可以去做下次的一个邀约，做下次的一个约会的一个铺垫，可以让你更安全的去做
说话人 1: 长期的一些建设
说话人 1: OK，然后后面就是女生的一个跟他制定约会地点的一个情况，然后还有后续的一些操作
说话人 1: OK，这是他们去约足浴
说话人 1: OK，这是见面的一个聊天
说话人 1: OK，他们当时还在玩什么游戏，对吧
说话人 1: 还是很有联系感的
说话人 1: OK，这是他一约之后回去的一个界面，做了一些联系感
说话人 1: 然后这是我们的第一部分，怎么去破解女生的废测
说话人 1: 怎么去破解女生的高位框架
说话人 1: 把女生给约出来，过程也是非常的曲折，然后用了很多的一些技巧，这是我们邀约部分
说话人 1: 在下一个部分，我们会详细讲解跟女生怎么在线上去把关系拉升
说话人 1: 直到一个男女朋友的一个位置，非常的干货兄弟们，特别是想要学习怎么在线上把女生给干住，全程干住，不敢出来跟女生见面，不敢去搭讪，不敢去什么，可以帮你在家里轻轻松松把妹子给干住，那就好好学习接下来的这一部分聊天
说话人 1: OK，我是Jackson，下期再见，兄弟们